how are you enjoying traveling and just  seeing the world and like doing club i'm  sure you're getting your your your bag  right you know what i'm saying yeah club  shows right everywhere we go how is it  though man like like just seeing new new  places and like going to cities that you  never thought you might go to you know  what i mean i mean it's fun like i  remember i remember i remember was doing  shows for 500  just just a year ago  that's crazy  what's it take to get you to come and do  a club hosting right now just to come  and do a host we gotta do a host for  like 10 come through do your record yeah  we do shows pop some bottles  like  went from 500 to 20 000 that's fire man  in a year  well congrats bro